hello everyone how you guys doing hope
you guys are having a wonderful day
today we were here with another video
and today's will be a quick little
money-making method that I actually
didn't intend on making a video about
today I planned on doing another video
but then looking into it this seemed to
be a really good method so basically
there are no requirements as far as I
can tell looking at the wiki I don't see
any requirements necessary if there were
to be any it would be farming but I
don't believe there is basically what
we'll be doing today is just making
ultra compost now there are there is
another method I think is willing to be
said and that is that if these margins
are dead people without anything at all
can also go to fossil Island if you have
the quest unlocked and I don't want to
talk to you buddy but if you go to
fossil Island which is up here and you
go around these parts you can mine
volcanic ash and that's going to be part
of what today's is if you are mining
those you can average a little over a
thousand an hour and they're currently
at 600 each so you can make 600 700 K
doing that however that's not what we'll
be doing today today we will be working
with margins instead over at the grand
exchange is just as you guys can see
here we have 3000 super compost buying
I'm not entirely sure if I'm going to
need to do all those that may be too
much but it's gonna give us a good idea
as to how many we can do in our super
compost right there as you guys can see
by for 437 GP per and then volcanic ash
is buying for 600 3 GB per not really
buying yet but in due time they will
come in worst comes to worst I can pay
another 17 GP per ash and that's
perfectly fine with me but basically
what we have going on here is you guys
can see you need to volcanic ash and one
super compost per bucket that you
actually do and basically whenever you
do this you'll be combining the two
ingredients to make an ultra compost now
with that said you'll be investing
sixteen hundred and forty GP ish and as
you guys can see over here I was able to
insist sell the Ultra compost for a 215
GP profit now that is pretty good
considering that's an insta sell you may
be able to slowly sell it for higher and
on top of that you make them relatively
quickly so you can make a pretty decent
amount per hour alright so there is a
huge revolution here that I didn't even
know earlier whenever I did this and
tested it for a second to see if it was
actually worth doing I in sold the ultra
compost and I figured there'd be a
pretty slim margin on it because you
know it's a pretty heavily traded new
item but there's 150 GP margin as you
guys can see here I sold them before
18:55 and I bought one and then realized
you could sell it for 2,000 that means
that we're making 10k per inventory
which is definitely really nice just off
of making some super compost into ultra
compost and with that said you do end up
spending about 30 seconds per inventory
and if you can make 10k per inventory
that comes out to you know about 1.2 ml
per hour with literally no were
quirements now there is one thing that I
will go ahead and add and that's a fact
that super compost you have a buy limit
of 600 it seems every four hours so you
will have to work around that now the
one way to do that is just constantly
have an offer and because if you do that
every four hours you're going to be able
to buy some and that means six times a
day you can buy 600 which means you can
buy 3600 a day with that knowledge you
can make about 1.5 mil per day off of
this money making method and it's only
going to take you about a little over an
hour you'll be making 1.2 mil per hour
and over time if you do this for an
entire day and you buy the super compost
you're going to end up being able to
make 1.5 mil a day with no real
requirement so I feel like this is
something that's really good for pretty
much anyone it could either be a passive
thing that you buy and then eventually
when you're stocked up on a lot you end
up just making them all or it could be
kind of a daily thing that you do to
make 1.5 mil I'm gonna go ahead and just
do a little bit more just because it
makes a decent amount of money and I
just want to make sure that the numbers
are all hammered out alright so I just
finished off the video but I guess I
never really showed exactly how to make
this it's pretty self-explanatory
basically volcanic ash is stackable so
you have just one slot in your inventory
then you pull out 27 super compost now
there are other ways to make this if
you're actually using a compost bin you
can use the volcanic ash on the bin and
it'll turn the bin into ultra compost
however that I mean that's not the
method oh so basically go ahead and just
press make all and then wait 30 seconds
in your inventories done it's a pretty
simple but I figure I'd show one
inventory and so here we are went ahead
and did 600 which is how many you can
buy every four hours now basically going
off of that we have a calculator right
here we can go ahead and look at what
you can expect so the initial price for
all this was 16 400 per one now if we go
ahead and subtract 2000 that'll give us
I mean two thousand to sell price so
this will give us a profit that we make
three
sixty per one now if we go 360 times 600
you can expect to make 216 K now the
real impressive thing about this is 216
K whether or not you're buying these
super combos non-stop you still can make
216 K just in 11 minutes of work now
with that said obviously you can make a
little bit more if you end up buying it
in stock so I mean 216 right here you
can make more close to 1.2 mil per hour
or even on top of that you can make 1.5
mil per day if you're constantly buying
super compost so hopefully this video
was helpful for you guys it's a really
good low level money making method that
I was really happy to find and hopefully
you guys can utilize it one thing I will
recommend before you go ahead and try
this check the margins before you buy
2000 of each and end up losing money
because this video may have heard it in
addition to that I'd like to say that if
you think this method is ruined because
it's not great right now that's exactly
the reason that the method will be good
in the future so many people watch these
videos and think well the method may be
useless within the first day or two that
it's out it won't be useful in the
future disregard it in the future that's
why it's good is because people forget
but for those of you that care you can
store it away for the later times where
you need a little bit of cash but
hopefully you guys enjoyed the video if
you guys did make sure to leave a like
if there's anything you want to tell me
or anything you want to comment about
feel free to down below subscribe to the
channel if you want to see my content in
the future soon as it goes live but with
that said hopefully guess have a
wonderful day and peace also Twitter in
the description devil